Нові податки, ліки за рецептом і повна заборона "кульочків".
Яких нововведень українцям чекати в новому 2022 році?
Розповідаємо про найважливіші.
У 2022-му "мінімалка" зросте на 200 гривень і становитиме 6700 гривень.
Підвищення запланували аж на 1 жовтня.
Попереднє зростання було в грудні 2021-го - з шести до шести з половиною тисяч гривень.
Тож наступне відклали ближче до кінця 2022-го, аби не штовхати вгору інфляцію.
За словами експертів, саме по собі підвищення "мінімалки" на 200 гривень за рік українську валюту значно не знецінить.
Утім, потягне за собою зростання єдиного соціального внеску, який підприємці сплачують за найманих працівників.
А якщо ростуть податки - ростуть і ціни.
Ще одне важливе нововведення для підприємців - касові апарати з першого січня.
Цю зміну вже кілька разів відкладали, бо ФОПи регулярно виходили на протести.
Нововведення торкнеться не всіх підприємців.
Чимало з них уже мають касові апарати.
До того ж, реформа стосуватиметься ФОПів, які мають найманих працівників -
це підприємці другої, третьої і четвертої груп спрощеної системи оподаткування.
Іншими словами, зміни зачеплять 150 тисяч ФОПів з майже двох мільйонів зареєстрованих в Україні.
Касові апарати повинні будуть з'явитися в ресторанах, кафе, турагенціях, готелях, інтернет-магазинах, звичайних крамницях.
Усюди, де розрахунок ведеться готівкою, картою, талонами чи жетонами, покупець має отримувати фіскальний чек.
В уряді кажуть: запровадження касових апаратів дозволить вивести бізнес з тіні й бачити його реальні обороти.
Адже дані одразу надходитимуть податківцям.
Противники реформи стверджують, що вона боляче вдарить по малому бізнесу.
Від "мінімалки" залежать ще кілька податків.
Наприклад, податок на нерухомість.
Власники великих квартир понад 100 квадратних метрів і будинків понад 120 мають платити збір за так би мовити "зайві" квадрати.
За кожен квадратний метр - по півтора відсотка "мінімалки".
З 2022 року це по 90 гривень за квадрат, тобто на 20 відсотків більше.
Податок сплачує власник раз на рік і незалежно від того, скільки людей живуть чи прописані в оселі.
З нового року запрацюють і нові податки для власників земельних паїв.
За ділянки в дачних кооперативах і в межах населеного пункту не треба буде платити.
Податок стосується тих, хто має земельні ділянки сільгосппризначення поза населеними пунктами.
За ділянки в місті чи селі треба платити, якщо вони більші 50 соток.
Не дешевше двох гривень. Такою буде мінімальна ціна одного пластикового пакета з першого лютого 2022 року.
А якщо він має ручки, то коштуватиме три гривні.
Утім, ідеться не про тонкі "маєчки", а про пакети товщиною понад 50 мікрометрів.
Це ті, що можуть витримати вагу більше семи кілограмів.
У грудні 2021-го уряд заборонив поширювати будь-які пластикові пакети безкоштовно.
А з березня 2022 року тонкі і надтонкі "кульочки" взагалі планують заборонити.
Пандемія коронавірусу триває, а отже, і необхідність вакцинації від "ковіду" в 2022-му зберігатиметься.
З 17 січня щеплення буде обов'язковим для медиків, а також для працівників органів
місцевого самоврядування й комунальних підприємств та організацій.
Ті, хто вже двічі щепився, можуть сподіватися на третю - так звану бустерну дозу.
У МОЗ обіцяють почати такі щеплення для людей з груп ризику вже із середини січня,
а більш масово - з січня-лютого. Утім жодних офіційних наказів міністерства поки немає.
З 1 квітня 2022 стартує черговий етап медреформи.
Він стосуватиметься медзакладів так званої третинної ланки.
Вони надають високоспеціалізовану допомогу за допомогою спеціального обладнання пацієнтам з тяжкими захворюваннями.
Це, приміром, інститути Нацакадемії медичних наук.
Такі медзаклади з квітня перейдуть на фінансування за програмою медичних гарантій і схему "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".
Ще одне медичне нововведення.
З 1 квітня МОЗ зобов'язав лікарів виписувати електронні рецепти на препарати, які в інструкції називаються рецептурними.
Згодом у відомстві роз'яснили: з квітня запровадять обов'язковий електронний рецепт для антибіотиків.
А до кінця року правило розширять щодо всіх рецептурних препаратів.
Отримати електронний рецепт можна буде у сімейного лікаря.
Рецепт з'явиться в електронній системі охорони здоров'я, а пацієнту надійде код в СМС-повідомленні.
Його і треба буде показати в аптеці.
Чергові норми мовного закону набудуть чинності 2022 року.
З 16 січня друковані ЗМІ мають випускатися державною мовою.
Для видань іншими мовами обов'язково має бути український аналог.
Ці вимоги не поширюються на ЗМІ, які виходять кримськотатарською, англійською чи мовами ЄС.
А з 16 липня за порушення мовного закону зможуть штрафувати конкретних людей.
Приміром, не кафе, де не обслуговують українською, а окремого офіціанта.
Або ж посадовців чи чиновників.
У сфері послуг штрафи будуть від 3400 до 5100 гривень.
Покарання для держслужбовців може сягати 6800 гривень.
В офісі мовного омбудсмена наголошують, що штрафуватимуть лише злісних порушників.
"Закон про основи національного спротиву" набуває чинності з 1 січня.
За документом, в Україні мають розгорнути військові частини територіальної оборони.
Окремі батальйони вже тренуються в різних містах.
Утім, з 2022 року всю систему планують зробити більш організованою.
Планується створити чотири регіональні управління.
У кожній області сформують свою бригаду тероборони.
Підрозділи розгорнуть до 15 січня.
Підписати контракт про військову службу зможе кожен охочий за місцем проживання.